emmanuel macron sur le point de fouler
le sol de kiev selon plusieurs médias et
notamment à du journal italien
repubblica regardez cette photo emmanuel
macron fait route en ce moment par le
train il est aux côtés ici du chancelier
allemand olaf scholz et du président du
conseil italien mario draghi
direction donc kiev pour une rencontre
inédite avec volodymyr zelensky on
retrouve justement à kiev l'envoyé
spécial de france 24 pauline godard
bonjour pauline on vient de le voir sur
cette photo emmanuel macron est en route
pour kiev
oui en effet ce sera la première fois
qu'il vient ici en ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre nos informations à
confirmer la la photo que vous venez de
montrer emmanuel macron serait donc bien
en route il serait dans le train avec
mario draghi le président du conseil
italien et avec également le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz il vient avec les
dirigeants européens de deux autres pays
fondateur de l'union européenne
emmanuelle mignon macro vient donc en
tant que président français mais aussi
en tant que président de du conseil
européen de l'union européenne la date
et est bien choisi puisque demain la
commission européenne doit rendre son
avis vous savez depuis le début de ce
conflit en ukraine est bien le président
les élèves qui réclament de rentrer dans
l'union européenne et la commission
européenne doit donc rendre son avis est
dire si elle est favorable pour accorder
un statut de candidat à l'ukraine est
d'ailleurs issu la vente des relayeurs
étaient là en début de semaine ici à
kiev et en a discuté avec le président
zelensky cette adhésion je vous le
disais elle est réclamée depuis des
semaines et des semaines par le
président les élèves qui tout comme ses
quasi quotidiens tout comme la demande
de d'armes supplémentaires alors ce
voyage est une étape essentielle
également avant le conseil de l'europe
qu'ils soient qui doit se tenir les 23
et 24 juin et puis ce sera aussi juste
avant la fin de l'après danse française
puisqu'elle se terminera le fin juin la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
un des dossiers je vous le disais qu'il
sera évidemment sur la table c'est ce
problème de livraison à d'armes il ya
encore quelques jours la vice-ministre
de la défense expliqué que kiev n'avait
reçu que 10 % des armes qu'elle réclame
haus occidentaux emmanuel macron est
très attendue donc ici c'est une visite
attendue mais vous le savez emmanuel
mâcon n'est pas forcément apprécié il ya
eu beaucoup de critiques notamment avec
ce qu'avait dit emmanuel macron sur la
rue s'il avait dit qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la russie des propos qui
avaient froissé notamment kiev hier
depuis la roumanie emmanuel macron
semble s'être expliqué sans doute une
façon d'avoir préparé les terres le
terrain vont son voyage ici à kiev il a
rappelé depuis la roumanie je cite la
clarté de la position française de
soutien à l'ukraine sans aucune
complaisance à l'égard de moscou